all right I have one last story I found
that made me smile hopefully you'll feel
the same this is what I'm
[Music]
liking I don't care what age you are
every person deserves to have love
companionship and frankly a little
pampering that's exactly what a New York
woman is promoting with her group
glamour gals for the past two decades
she's recruited teens to join her at
senior homes they hang out with the
residents while also doing their nails
their hair little makeovers that make
everybody feel beautiful um on the
inside and out it's nice um we have the
founder of Glamour gals on the line
right now watching on NBC New York
what's up
Rachel hi we I actually used to do this
with my church group whenever I was a
kid we used to do something similar to
this and that's how it was introduced to
me but where did you come up with the
idea it's actually in honor of my own
grandmother I wanted to give her a
beauty makeover but she lived in a
senior home across the country and it
just never happened happened so when she
passed away I wanted to honor her and so
I had this idea of going into my local
senior home and providing Beauty
makeovers to the residents who live
there to sit down to connect to share a
compliment and a story and just make
someone feel loved and appreciated and
it was actually at my first makeover I
had two friends just two friends show up
but from there two decades later we've
inspired thousands of team volunteers to
do the same and it's as valuable to them
as it is to us and uh every everybody we
serve yeah absolutely so you have a
special holiday project right that's
right absolutely our my dear friend card
writing campaign wants to reach as many
seniors as possible anyone can write
holiday notes even kids and we pair them
with seniors around the country our goal
is to reach 30,000 isolated seniors with
cards this holiday season so please get
writing so cool I love that even the pin
pal thing in general and I even love how
like a kid you know with a grandparent
you know kind of age person like that's
a really cool thing just to see what we
cultivate from that kind of relationship
that's really that's a super cool idea
um thank you so much um if you want to
be part of my dear friend cards check
out our insta story for info you got to
check that out everybody thank you so
much Rachel what a beautiful thing
you're doing I'm liking your post right
now okay and that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 the
go-to pin at the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable people
just like you ma'am so they're going to
be riding glamour goals a check for
$1,000 how's that
sound that'll help with some
supplies absolutely thank you Rachel and
thank you to all our guests this hour
uba HW Aaron lii Matt Rogers M
Jeff Kenny and Jacob you all have a
great day and if it's not try and change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home